speaking of being a powerful asian
american you saw nathan chen
yo shout out to nate this is the guy
right here dog this dude killed that
[ __ ] doing a real man sport yeah look at
this
lutz
sao cow something good
so he's killing this whole [ __ ] he's
just i think he's chinese like chinese
american no no he's american
he's american yeah
[ __ ] yeah
he's trying to eat a dog no no he's
american bro that's an american-ass kid
look at him yeah handsome kid pure sex
that guy yeah pure sex pure sex and then
his score came in he was like i think
one of the last people two japanese
people
in the rankings oh [ __ ]
that was perfect dude you're just
skipping through the most important
parts i'm about to show you the score
i'm going to show you the score yeah
yeah
look at that i think you got that that's
a quadruple right there nobody got a
triple triple toe
i've done a triple axle
one axle
hit a one and a half axle right yeah
yeah you got it you got it
by 40.
you're not landing in it was going back
i didn't land it no
you did no you got to stand up and then
you got to go like this at the end of it
like at the end of gymnastics
[Music]
you got to finish it like gymnastics i
gotta get one of these at the end for
america for america for america you got
it
[Laughter]
you can't land you can't match them no i
got i got tens of i got 100
you can't do 360 attempts no why yo
that's counting 30
you don't want to jump off for the white
you're going to lose a jump off to a
white man or a black history month oh
[ __ ]
every black person i understand i got
tim's up no every black person knows
that you could fight in tim's you could
run in tim's yeah you could jump intense
yeah stomp
stop
stop at 360. you might do one 360. it
might help you land cause you do it no
no no no no can't jump they're not
jumping oh
come on that's what i'm talking about
there we go there you go watch that
thing about to drop al
play the black national anthem
okay this is the black national anthem
okay here we go
that's 360. do five forty two five
now two five four seconds
okay let's see 540 then let's see 540
and then we're going to focus your
[ __ ] head on the corner
nope didn't stick it fell back like a
bump
stick it fell back like a bump
still fell back like a bum you can't
even stick
oh
i was ready to [ __ ] all over out and
then use the arms and that centripetal
force was [ __ ] amazing exactly
turned into a helicopter real quick
oh
i mean after your fist tired no no keep
it see what happens i'll see what
happens no but keep it a buck right
there when i found out how to use the
arms
[Laughter]
i stuck that landing bro
like that [ __ ] who broke her ankle in
the gymnastics
do you remember her
no the gymnastics [ __ ] from america she
broke her ankle but she was drunk that
one yeah oh i thought you told me nancy
carrick i honestly kept thinking of that
too
but she didn't break it
something on you will be broken by today
my neck hurts
i already stressed my neck so winded and
i'm [ __ ] winning bro
holy [ __ ] yeah we need some ac my farts
came out cause i took my jacket off
oh god
i tried to time my fart with the jump i
think it gave me a little bit more
elevation a little boost i knew that
last one i farted when i jumped and loki
that's why i spun so well i like that
you have to take off your jacket to get
that last one it's not cause if when i
spin it catches it
tips
you jump bro
they do help you jump yeah way better
than these yeah who's ever jumped in
those nobody ever checked the
[Laughter]
yeah to play basketball these were the
only sneakers that existed exactly and
they yeah
actually dr j didn't wear these he wore
tim's he did wear temps
he did he played basketball in temps he
was only on february
did they even have black history month
back then nah
when did we get it yeah i gotta look
that up that's a good ass it had to be
before mlk day otherwise it had
definitely done them shits on the same
day nah i think it's probably ours
uh 1970 1970 mlk day was reagan oh [ __ ]
it was january 2nd to february 28th 1970
oh kick away a month [ __ ] out of here
y'all lost a month bro yeah step it up
ask when they when they cut that month
off step it up yeah they're really
three-fifths of your history that's
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] son ain't got a wild
that's crazy that's crazy though two
months ago gerald ford is the one i
think that first recognized that as
president that was 1976. right out there
jesus shout out to gerald what are you
doing like the card
yeah what did they george washington
carver that [ __ ] down
that's crazy anyway shout out nathan
chen bro spun that whole [ __ ] yo got the
highest score ever american nathan chen
with the highest score ever shouts to
america
that's what i'm talking about my boy
let's go nathan yup did it wow body
everybody else that's what i'm talking
about five points higher [ __ ] in japan
they can't [ __ ] with us bro they can't
[ __ ] oh so we do it to them they just
get a little payback what you mean no
he's born and raised here yeah but you
still they see their own right now so
you don't think they're looking at that
it's like no you traitor
nah i think so they're looking at his
parents like that maybe
right his parents maybe they see that
but that [ __ ] don't don't ever
punish the sons for the sins of the
father out damn yeah damn that's a hero
dog he's a hero national hero yeah
[ __ ]
goal
that's the first goal we got right
first goal could have been eileen could
have been two [ __ ]
[ __ ]
four girls eighteen
okay old enough to hey hey you go to war
you get called [ __ ] both can happen
i said but that's island goo bro yeah
why why you cuck because she just she
got money she the only thing is that
she's not honest about it i agree with
that the only one
yeah that's my only criticism i have two
criticisms one just the fact that you
can do this
and two that she's lying about it and
she would have got money here you're
acting like a hot girl with a victoria's
secret contract it had one route to
money who was also accepted to stanford
oh my god she's not some [ __ ]
hopeless girl you know projects trying
to make it out no she can she's gonna
this this probably a middle-class girl
grew up with with resources enough to be
a [ __ ] skier do you think she grew up
poor as a skier no i don't think she's
great you know like poor skiers her mom
taught skiing yeah yeah it probably
wasn't poor at tahoe yeah it's yeah yeah
she was she lived in tahoe what a rough
upbringing she must have had yeah i
sympathize yeah just say my ass
low-key i would be all right i honestly
i'm not all right it'd be annoying but
i'd be like if she went yo america
didn't cough up the bag i wouldn't like
america was cheap america doesn't value
me i could respect you
in america
to value myself
and get paid the most that i possibly
can get paid for my duties now she's
still [ __ ] all over america and is a
traitor but at least she'd be honest and
i could uh respect her as an honest
human being she's our benedict arnold yo
real talk she's our best this is a
traitor she's a traitor dog it's gotta
be sympathizing for traitors the way he
became french last episode
what is up with you what you trying to
do
you need to visit your parents now you
know what it is
you've been away from home too long he's
about to turn on us that's what it is
sometimes you get other offers
because he for sale for china too oh
yeah yeah but i said that off rip though
what do you mean whoever treats me
better they will never treat you better
we don't know that they don't treat
their people better i haven't heard that
it's the last time your people were
purchased it didn't go well okay i
wouldn't put yourself up for sale i
haven't heard their offer hey hey hey if
you think they treat the uyghurs badly
[Laughter]
i'm not going to finish that sentence
but i think we know where it's going
where is it going i don't know
i don't know akash
you